nicki minaj made her grand return with a
brand new single do we have a problem
featuring little baby the singer stopped
by the late late show with james corden
to promote the new track where she
showed off another talent yeah nikki
delivered a spot-on impression of
adele's british accent after adele sang
an epic rendition of nikki's hit monster
during a carpool karaoke segment six
years ago so good take care everyone bye
what does nicki minaj's
impression of adele sound like oh my
goodness
um
all right in order for me to channel
adele
i sort of have to think like i'm black
lazy in london
right because the thing is
normally everybody knows i told my
british accent it's sort of like a a
posh white lady a rich white lady right
but with adele i sort of have to like
transform like like you know like she
you might might have used to sell crack
like maybe she
like maybe she used to be like hustling
like nickels and dimes in the hood and
then and then you know like she got her
big break because that that's what i see
when i see her like she's always like
it's so expressive right